como si él mismo fuera ese Adán
con su dedo buscando
y casi tocando la mano de Dios.
La maestría es el buscar, no el llegar.
Es la búsqueda constante de cerrar la brecha
entre lo que se es y lo que se quiere ser.
La maestría es sacrificarse por su arte
y no por hacer una carrera.
¿Cuántos inventores y emprendedores anónimos
viven esto?
Vemos esto incluso en la vida
del explorador del ártico Ben Saunders
que me dijo que su triunfo
no es únicamente el resultado
de un gran logro,
sino el resultado de una cadena de casi lograrlo.
Progresamos cuando superamos nuestros límites.
Es una sabiduría que entendió Duke Ellington
cuando dijo que su canción favorita de su repertorio
era siempre la siguiente,
siempre la que aún no componía.
Parte de la razón del casi lograrlo
en lograr la maestría
es porque a mayor sea nuestro desempeño,
más claramente podemos ver
que no sabemos todo lo que creíamos.
Se le llama el efecto Dunning-Kruger.
James Baldwin,
cuando le preguntaron para The Paris Review,
"¿Qué crees que incrementa el conocimiento?"
respondió "Aprender que sabes muy poco".
El éxito nos motiva, pero el casi lograrlo
nos catapulta a una búsqueda constante.
Uno de los ejemplos más vívidos de esto es
cuando vemos la diferencia
entre los medallístas olímpicos de plata
y los de bronce después de la competencia.
Thomas Gilovich y su equipo de Cornell
estudiaron esta diferencia y encontraron
que la frustración que sufren los ganadores de plata
comparada con la de los de bronce, que están un poco
más felices no haber llegado en cuarto lugar
y no ganar ninguna medalla,
les da a los ganadores de la plata
un objetivo para mejorar en la competencia.
Vemos esto incluso en la industria de las apuestas
en el que aplicamos este fenómeno
del casi lograrlo
y creamos los billetes de rascar
que tiene un promedio de casi ganadores mayor
y así compelemos a que compren más billetes
que se conocen como ganafáciles
y se utilizó en la serie de abusos de la industria de apuestas
en Inglaterra durante la década de los 70s.
La razón del porqué casi ganar da esta propulsión
es porque cambia nuestra manera de ver las cosas
y pone nuestras metas, a las que tendemos a poner
a la distancia, más cerca
de donde estamos.
Si les pidiera que pensaran cómo sería un gran día la próxima semana
lo describirían en términos generales.
Pero si les preguntara cómo sería un gran día en el TED de mañana
puede que lo describan con claridad granular y práctica.
Y esto es lo que el casi lograrlo hace.
Nos hace concentrarnos, en este momento,
en lo que planeamos para alcanzar las estrellas.
Es Jackie Joyner-Kersee, que en 1984
perdió el oro en heptatlón
por un tercio de segundo
y su esposo predijo que eso le daría
la tenacidad para seguir en la competencia
En 1988 ganó el oro en heptatlón
e impondría una marca de 7291 puntos,
una marca a la que ningún atleta se ha acercado desde entonces.
Progresamos no cuando ya hicimos todo,
sino cuando aún hay algo por hacer.
Pienso e imagino
en las distintas formas
de casi lograrlo
en este salón,
cómo sus vidas lo tomarían,
porque creo que en cierto nivel lo sabemos.
Sabemos que progresamos cuando estamos
en nuestro propio límite
y es por eso que la incompetencia deliberada
está en la creación de los mitos.
En la cultura navajo, algunos artesanos y mujeres
deliberadamente ponen imperfecciones
en sus textiles y cerámicas.
Es lo que se llama una línea de espíritu,
un error deliberado en el patrón
para mostrar el creador o al tejedor,
pero también una razón para seguir trabajando.
Los maestros no son expertos porque
hayan llevado algo a su final conceptual.
Son maestros porque se dan cuenta
que no existe uno.
Pienso, mientras hablo de esto,
en el porqué el entrenador de los arqueros
me dijo al final de la práctica,
lejos de los oídos de los arqueros,
que él y sus colegas sienten que nunca
pueden dar lo suficiente por sus equipos,
sienten no hay suficientes técnicas de visualización
ni entrenamientos de posturas con los que les ayuden a superar
ese casi lograrlo.
No sonaba como una queja, exactamente,
sino como para dejarme saber,
para admitir algo,
para recordarme que se estaba entregando
a una tarea voraz e incompleta
que siempre requiere algo más.
Nos construimos a partir de una idea inacabada,
aún cuando esa idea sea nuestro anterior yo.
Esta es la dinámica de la maestría.
Acercarse a lo que pensaban que querían
puede ayudarlos a obtener más de
lo que nunca hayan soñado.
Es lo que imagino que Elizabeth Murray
pensaba cuando la vi sonreír
sobre esas primeras obras
en la galería.
Aún si creamos utopías, creo
que debemos dejarlas incompletas.
La completud es la meta,
pero espero que nunca sea el final.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)